[Music]
if a lion needs someone and you lock it
up when you say don't do that again and
ten years later you let it out what
happens
total criminals rebels I'm talking about
the endless voice in a Predators head
let's just do it do it do it sexy really
[Music]
it's happening to me I've disarmed you
it's still there but it's no longer
possible for you to get an erection
grace what have you done of it sinus
your savings will be divided amongst the
girls rube used to be what I chase they
live in the dark and I could see them
really easily
you comin I'm bored I want to go home
young girl in here she left already
we can't go knocking down doors I sit on
the line right down right this second
and here we are talking says that he's
fitted a girl with a tracker and he's
using her as bait get out there and find
out Simon has multi-personality treats
each with their own realities but I
don't know if you didn't aware of that
[Music]
[Music]
the girl is gone this so we caught him
he's right there
he's been in my house that's impossible
let me say I'm sorry for the things that
time
and then I'll tell you where the last
one
[Music]
Simon's got friends
[Music]
[Applause]
when you find them
[Music]
tick-tock tick-tock tick-tock
[Music]
[Music]
you